you know i think something we don't do
enough as a follow-up i think something
we don't do enough is following we don't
sit there
they say napoleon any time before he
went to war he would take a week sit in
a room with a lot of paper and stuff to
write on
and he would just strategize okay what
if we did this what if the enemy did
this what's their strength who's the
strength
who's the best trainer here who does he
have how many soldiers did that which
and then he would look at the maps and
think about the quality of maps back
then terrain
like the mountains you know the water
all the stuff you don't have the kind of
map that we have today so he's using you
know low
quality stuff that it's just hey i think
this is what it looks like and it's this
many miles away and this many kilometers
away
but he would sit there then he would
come back out and have a meeting with
his soldiers and say hey
here's what we're going to be doing you
and your soldiers are going here
this unit you're going here if they
attack from here is this the strength of
this army is this the strength of the
army is this
here's what they're going to be doing
this is the seasons who's trained to be
able to do this you guys have been most
prepared to go on the mountain terrain
you're going to go here you guys have
been most
for forests you're going to go here you
guys have been cold you guys
so then he would put his plan of action
and then he would go out and they would
ask him and say hey
napoleon whose strategy do you use the
most when it comes down to where you
know what his answer was
no one's that's what made him
predictable unpredictable right so the
enemy didn't know
what he was gonna do yeah because if you
reveal you're using someone's strategy
guess what the enemy's gonna do
i know exactly what your next move is to
be then then there's that element of
you know i know exactly what you're
going to do so i know how to pivot
myself so
in life it's the same exact thing and by
the way
this isn't about being a billionaire
this isn't about being a millionaire
this isn't about
ferraris and lambos and 20 000 square
foot homes on the ocean and this isn't
about that this isn't about
having dinner with the presidents and
all nope
this is you there's seven and a half
billion people living in the world
there's no one in the world that's more
important than you to you
what i mean by i don't mean selfishly i
mean
no my son i'm spending time with him
right now today was at the office and
they just left right now
we're at lunch we're having this seafood
right i'm having some oysters and he's
sitting there in a corner
from the moment he sat down he knew what
he wanted
he wanted to play the santa claus game
do you know how many times he asked me
that can i play the santa claus game
that can i play the santa claus game
can i play it now i said dad one minute
that i'm on the phone
one minute later dad it's been a minute
can i play the game now can i play it
again
he is so persistent it's
ridiculous how many times he asked me
what he wants
his brother's slightly different his
sister's slightly different
what he likes my middle one doesn't like
my youngest doesn't my youngest
temperament is demanding
she wants everything you better respect
what she wants
so as these guys age i can't say hey why
don't you go be an entrepreneur like
your dad it's not going to be the case
they're all going to be different
because the most important person that
matters
in the equation of knowing what you want
to do next is who you
that's all that matters so if i sit down
in quiet time and i say let's just say
i'm bobby johnny patrick
hafiz whoever you are you're sitting
there saying you know what i really want
to do
let me tell you when i grew up i
remember when i was going through this
and i saw foster
here's what i want to do yesterday i
interviewed a guy that's a former ci
agent i don't know if you've seen the
movie jack ryan he's the real life jack
ryan wow
former ci agent that was a pair rescue
agent that's now
his entire mission today is human
trafficking why human trafficking
like why did he wake up one day want to
do human trafficking
foster care is where he came out of 60
of human trafficking comes up
so look at the connection of what drove
him to want to do that
makes sense i grew up extremely poor i
grew up not having anything i'm a
welfare kid i escaped iran to come here
so politically why am i such a
protective capitalism in
entrepreneurship
because i've been on the other side well
you can't say anything you better be
quiet you got to walk on exiles
but that's my story what's yours what's
the individuals i think very
very rarely do people take the most
important time out of the life
which is your time out and you sit there
quietly and say okay i'm 28 years old
what have i done so far yeah not much
i'm not happy with it i'm 42 years old
what's the next move and you sequence it
out and you go execute
[Music]